hello welcome to 3abn today Bible q a my
name is Angela McKay I'm glad that you
have tuned in you're going to be blessed
by this program
well this is a program where you get
your Bible questions answered and if you
have questions that you would like to
send in to us you can do that by going
to Bible QA at 3abn.tv or you can send
your text 2618-228-3975
well before we get into the program
allow me to introduce our panel and
today we have Shelley Quinn Shelly glad
to be here what do you like about q a
I like what I learned you know it's it's
fun to research some questions maybe
that you don't know but I really learned
from everybody that we sit with
none of us can ever know too much about
the word of God that's true amen all
right thank you Pastor James Rafferty
welcome thank you it's really good to be
here isn't it yes and what do you like
about Bible q a well what I like Angie
is the opportunity to help people to try
to understand difficult questions that
may be troubling and bothering them that
was my problem and it has been my
problem with the Bible is I come across
something I just yeah what does this
mean right and when you get an answer to
something like that it really can change
your whole focus and relationship with
God Amen you could always learn
something new huh in the word of God I
know I do all right and cross from me is
my sweetheart Pastor John Loma King
welcome and what do you like about Bible
q a well to me the Bible is an ocean and
every time I go and I realize I don't
have enough oxygen I always learn
something more it's so deep baby that um
people ask questions that sometimes
sound basic but when we do the research
like one of the questions I have today
when we do the research it opens up
something that I never knew and so thank
you for challenging us it's also helping
us to learn more amen amen
amen thank you for your support of 3abn
this worldwide Ministry and especially
your prayers
speaking of prayers I'm going to ask
Shelley Quinn to open with prayer we'd
love to our glorious and wonderful
Heavenly Father we come before you today
Lord we dedicate this time to you we ask
in the name of Jesus help us to be out
of the way speak through us send your
Holy Spirit to anoint us and to anoint
every ear that hears including ours
father we love your word it is a lamp to
our feet and a light to our path and
help us all to understand by the power
of the Holy Spirit we give you all the
praise all the glory in Jesus name amen
amen thank you
well the pro program format is three
minutes for each question and we also
have a four minute question answer I
should say not a question and so right
now we're going to start with our first
question honey you're going to get the
four minute one okay all right here we
go
why do Seventh-Day Adventists adhere to
certain laws eat enough clean animals
while not others mix in Fabrics
it seems like Masonic Judaism as
acceptable and acknowledgment of Christ
however still observing Jewish practices
this is Jacoby from Oklahoma now thank
you for the questions Jacoby this is one
of those questions I talked about that
helps us learn something that is not a
part of our daily intellect I did some
research and we have to go back now not
not today where Fabrics are all on a
large spool and factories and we just
pick the different colors the silks the
wall the rayon the polyesters the the
mixed Fabrics but go back to the time
where they literally had to kill an
animal to make a garment and according
to the Jews if you mixed the different
skins they said they wore differently
when they dried some dried quicker than
others some stretched quicker some
shrunk more than others and so when you
go back Josephus the historian and a
number of other Hebrew writers
contributed the fact that in the Hebrew
economy even in the sanctuary Services
they believed that in order for the
Garment to maintain its longevity that
they should not mix the different animal
skins together the other aspect of it
was when the Hebrews were in Egypt they
got their Fabrics from the markets in
Egypt and they chose Fabrics that were
identified as closely as it possibly
could be to the kind of fabrics they had
when they were in their own land and so
whenever they mixed Fabrics they said
don't mix a Hebrew fabric with an
Egyptian Fabric and they believed that
to be mixing the holy with the Unholy
today very interesting to see how they
did that so Rabbi Abraham isakuk
suggested that wearing wool from sheep
at some level is a form of theft or if
he wore from different animals so they
had their traditional beliefs that
prevented them from mixing these Fabrics
together
but that was not the same principle when
it came to deciding what to eat because
deciding what to eat was established
long before Jews even existed as a
matter of fact in Genesis 1 29
the Lord is speaking to Adam and Eve
said
I have given you every herb that yields
seed which is on the face of all the
Earth and every tree whose fruit yields
seed to you it shall be for food long
before the Jews existed there were no
Jews in existence at all and so the
foods that we add here to or practice uh
in a health way as Seventh-Day
Adventists we try to trace it back to
creation and we know that we're
thousands of years removed we have GMOs
and all that type of chemical
enhancements today but still the Lord
made a distinction between the clean and
the unclean and the food that was
healthier for pre-sin man and then even
though he added vegetables and post the
post flood era still today the cleanest
and the healthiest diet are those of
fruits grains vegetables nuts and
although we like soda and I'd I
confessed how I like barbecue potato
chips I'm learning how to get over
eating all of that even though that is
not a synonym of itself the Lord made it
very clear even to the generation of
Noah in Genesis 7 verse 2 you shall take
with you seven each of every clean
animal a male and this female to each of
animals that are unclean a male and a
female why because on the other side of
the flood vegetation would be destroyed
and the Lord designated long before Jews
clean animals and unclean animals and
when you do the research all the hard
shell animals in the ocean all the hard
shellfish are God's sanitation
department the pigs are scavengers most
of the birds of prey are scavengers
except for chicken a turkey but you find
that the Bible clearly in Deuteronomy 14
in Leviticus chapter 11 outlines the
dietary principles but what's the
overriding factor First Corinthians 10
verse 31 therefore whether you eat or
drink or whatever you do do all to the
glory of God our bodies is a residing
place of the Holy Spirit and you'll find
the healthier the body as in Daniel's
day the clearer the mind the greater the
intellect and the better God can
communicate with us and we can
communicate with the Lord amen so the
dietary Foods were not just for the Jews
well not at all they were just stewards
of that to let the world know and
understand through what God entrusted to
them how we should eat like the Bible
says I pray that you prosper and be in
health even as your soul prospers thank
you so much for that great
okay here we go Pastor Rafferty here's
your question you have an interesting
question that's interesting I had to
look this one up
can you explain First Timothy 5 verse 23
Andy from West Salem Illinois all right
Andy from West Salem Illinois yes First
Timothy 5 and verse 23 here's what it
says drink no longer water but use
little wine for thy stomach's sake and
thine oft infirmity says the King James
version you know the other day my wife
and I were eating grapes and she said to
me you are eating
Resveratrol Resveratrol you're eating
Resveratrol wow what is that and it's
good for you she said my wife always
tells me when I'm eating food that's
good for me okay so this is an
ingredient in grapes that is really good
for your health it's called around
Resveratrol and some people think that
because fermented grapes or alcohol
are beneficial to you that's what the
research says that it's good to drink a
little wine every once in a while a
little alcohol every once in a while but
it's actually the Resveratrol that is
the good part and you don't need to
ferment grapes or fermented wine in
order to get that good part and the
benefits of that good part
so some even say that you know fermented
wine is good for you because
um it helps you relax or it helps you
know relieve the
stress of the day or Etc well whenever
I'm studying alcohol in the Bible I like
to share with people two verses the
first one is found in Proverbs chapter
31 and I'll just begin with verse 4 it
says it is not for Kings Ola mule it's
not for Kings to drink wine for nor for
princes strong drink verse 5 lest they
drink and forget the law and pervert the
Judgment of any of The Afflicted so God
is saying here very clearly we shouldn't
be drinking alcohol we shouldn't be
drinking fermented wine then he goes on
in verse six he says give strong drink
unto him that is ready to perish and
whine unto those that be of heavy hearts
now this this verse verse 6 is a
difficult one because you think wait a
minute God is saying that we should
actually give alcohol and wine to people
well
the reason people drink primarily is to
forget their troubles the reason people
drink primarily is it's what we call a
comfort that's there's some alcohol
that's actually called Southern Comfort
and the point is is that God is called
us to be Kings and pre and priests in
Revelation chapter 1 verse six it says
we're Kings and Priests as a chosen
generation and we are not perishing the
Bible says in John 3 16 God so loved the
world that whosoever believeth in him
should not perish but have everlasting
life so we have a comforter and that
comforter is Jesus and Jesus has given
us the Holy Ghost to comfort us so when
you're going through stress and when
you're going through trials and when
you're dabbing a difficult time don't
turn to the bottle don't turn to alcohol
you can get all of the benefit from
Those Grapes without the alcohol turn to
the Lord Jesus Christ give your troubles
your burdens to him and let him be the
one who takes all of that stress away
from you do not act as though your
perishing and turned to alcohol but turn
to your savior Jesus Christ well said so
many people go for a glass of wine
before they go to bed right
it's to relax them they don't need it as
you said the word you need the Lord the
Holy Spirit that's a prayer
amen a glass of prayer before you go to
bed not the wine thank you for that okay
Mrs Shelley Quinn here it goes here's
your question I was recently baptized
and my head was covered with a shower
cap
why was my head covered and because of
this am I truly baptized
I am asking this because I've never seen
anyone baptized with a covering to
protect their hair this is Annette from
Brooklyn New York no Annette
Annette you're looking at somebody who's
been baptized four times once when I was
12 because that was the time that you
made that decision
didn't take though I'll tell you why in
a minute once when I was 18 because in a
New Testament Church I heard a sermon
that if I hadn't been
baptized correctly I was going straight
to you nowhere once when I was 28
because I went down to join a the
membership in a church that had been
Baptist and now was non-denominational
and they dumped me before I knew what
happened oh dear and then
the time I was truly baptized was when I
was 38 years old I'm going to tell you
up front a hair covering does not make a
difference between you being accepted to
the Lord are you truly baptized only one
way can we tell if you are truly
baptized here is what the Lord opened to
me and made me realize I'd never really
been baptized those first three times
Romans chapter 6 will begin with verse
4. Romans 6 4 therefore you were buried
with him through baptism into death that
just as Christ was raised from the dead
by the glory of the father even so we
also should walk in newness of Life
baptism represents the burial the death
the burial and the resurrection of Jesus
Christ
baptism in when we are truly baptized it
is because we went into this practice
understanding what was about to happen
to us he says for if we've been United
together in the likeness of his death
certainly we shall also be in the
likeness of his resurrection knowing
this that our old man was crucified with
him that the body of sin might be done
away with that we should no longer be
slaves to sin and that if you went to
your baptism realizing that God was
doing something in you that he'd done a
change and you're there to say Lord I'm
here to identify with you I am laying
down my old life that old self it's
being buried under the water I'm going
to be
resurrected Lord United with you then
you're truly baptized and it says in
verse seven I've got just a little time
so I'll read it he who has died has been
freed from sin now if we died with
Christ we know that we shall also live
with him baptism is a white funeral
baptism is laying down an old life and
if you
did that and were ready to raise and
walk in newness of life then you're
truly baptized amen amen that's right
and it doesn't matter if your head is
covered does it so be baptized I don't
think God's up there saying whoops her
hair didn't get well actually when I got
baptized I had a swimming cap on
and I was baptized and God accepted my
baptism praise the lord well if you've
just tuned in and you have questions
that you would like to send in to us you
can email us at bibleqa at
3abn.tv or you can text us your question
to
618-228-3975 all right here we go
uh Pastor John my sweetie are you ready
I'm ready
okay here we go in Isaiah 59 18 God
tells us that we will be punished
according to our deeds and I'm wondering
does that mean people that did horrible
things will get horrible repayment for
what they did not just simply die in the
fire this is from a viewer in California
okay wow you know that's a that's a very
good question uh to some degree it's
rhetorical because you you answered it
excluding the word horrible each of us
will be rewarded according to our deeds
and let me qualify that the righteous
are not rewarded according to their
deeds because there's no deed we can do
to purchase eternal life it's a gift to
the righteous this when it talks about
Revelation particular Revelation chapter
20 and all the passages in the Bible
Revelation 22 verse 12. you find
Ecclesiastes chapter 12 verse 13-14 let
me just read that for you Ecclesiastes
12 13 and 14 it says um let us hear the
conclusion of the whole matter fear God
and keep his Commandments for this is
the whole duty of man for God will bring
every work into judgment with every
secret thing whether it is good or
whether it is evil so yes the basis our
works are going to be examined and if we
have not repented then we will have to
face the penalty of the decisions that
we have made in life that's why Peter
said the answer is repent and be
converted that your sins may be blotted
out that was in Acts 3 and verse 19. so
instead of fearing the judgment and
fearing what's going to come our way
because we think wow I've done some
horrible things the best decision is to
repent and be converted if you confess
your sins he is faithful and just to
forgive you and cleanse you from all
unrighteousness but let me go ahead and
answer the questions to support the fact
that each one of us will face the reward
of or the a negative impact of our
decisions Matthew 12 36 but I say to you
that for Every Idle Word men speak they
will give an account in the day of
judgment for by your words you will be
justified and by your words you will be
condemned so I always said to saying
that I'll repeat it for you whatever you
say make it soft and sweet because one
day you might have to swallow it so but
think about what you say
second Corinthians 5 and verse 10 for we
must all appear before the judgment's
heat of Christ
that each one may receive the things
done in the body according to what he
has done whether good or bad or good or
evil based on whatever translation you
read and then Revelation 20
this is often referred to as the great
white Throne judgment more specifically
those who come up in the second
Resurrection Revelation 20 verse 12 and
I saw the dead small and great standing
before God and books were open and
another another book was opened which is
The Book of Life and the dead were
judged according to their works by the
things which were written in the book so
you see those who have not accepted
Christ those whose sins have not been
forgiven will have to face their deeds
in the resurrection so
it is it is sensible I mean the most
sensible thing to do is to follow first
John 1 9 confess amen God will forgive
you he'll cleanse you from all
unrighteousness and then according to
the Bible you will have boldness in the
day of judgment that's right that is
fearlessness amen and I'm glad you said
first John 1 9 we have to repent right
that's right confess confess to one
another and to God that's right thank
you for that okay
Pastor Rafferty here we go number two
probation is quote unquote closed at a
certain point in the Bible but isn't
probation closed for each of us at the
time of death this is from Terry in Ohio
yes Terry in Ohio that's a really good
point probation does close for each one
of us at death we have a verse for that
it's found in Hebrews chapter 9 verse
27. let me just read it to you it says
as it is uh appointed unto men wants to
die but after this the Judgment so death
seals up Our Fate if we have not make it
made a decision for Christ by the time
we die Our Fate is sealed and the next
thing we're going to know is the
judgment and of course some folks will
close their probation before death it's
possible for us according to the Bible
to commit what we call the unpardonable
sin or the sin against the Holy Spirit
and Jesus talks about this in Matthew
chapter 12 verses 31 and 32 and you can
read the references there but the thing
that we need to look at more closely is
this Final close of probation so we want
to make a decision of course before we
die we want to make a decision for
Christ because once we die probation is
closed as far as our decision making
goes we don't want to make a decision to
reject the Holy Spirit who seeks to
convict us and lead us to Jesus but at a
certain time in history probation is
going to close generally speaking and
that is found in Revelation chapter 22.
there are other places where we can see
this but revelation 22 is the clearest
it says here in verse 11. he that is
unjust let him be unjust still
he that is filthy let him be filthy
still he that is righteous let him be
righteous still he that is Holy let him
be holy still and behold I come quickly
and my reward is with me to give every
man according to his works or as his
work shall be as John was just sharing
so Jesus Christ is going to look out
upon planet Earth he's mediating right
now his blood in behalf of Sinners and
he is going to look out on planet Earth
one day after there's a great test
that's going to come upon this whole
world and he's going to say you know
what if I kept probation open for
another year or another month or another
week or another day or another minute or
Another Second it wouldn't make any
difference he is Holy is going to be
holy still that's what his righteous
going to be righteous still he this
filth he's going to be filthy still
we're just going to close this up might
as well head on in and bring those
people home who decided for me and let
the people receive the consequences of
their choices who've decided against me
so right now we need to think about this
and we need to realize that the reason
why we're still here the reason why
probation lingering years is because
second Peter 3 9 says yes God is
long-suffering toward us that's right
context of that Hey where's the promise
of his coming everything's continued
well our fathers fell asleep and they
were thinking I wouldn't even make it to
College you know and here I am you know
I'm getting ready to retire why hasn't
Jesus come yet because God is
long-suffering to us what he's not
willing that any would perish but that
all would come to repentance that's
right God is wanting he's yearning for
the hearts of every individual and as we
read there in Revelation chapter 22 he's
not he's not going to close it up until
the time when it won't make any
difference when no changes will be made
when no one's going to decide for
against him and then he's going to close
it all up so make a decision for Jesus
Christ while probation still lingers
amen amen well said I love the way you
answer that make your call in an
election sure listener thank you for
that okay Shelly
you got the baptism questions I did
didn't I this is our second one here it
is is it a requirement to be baptized by
immersion to enter Heaven this is from
Judy in Texas okay Judy I want to hit
this from two different directions is
baptism a part of our Salvation in his
baptism by immersion I wasn't quite
certain what you were asking but let me
just say this Christ made only two
ordinances for the gave two ordinances
to the church one is communion and that
was just acknowledge his death the other
is baptism which acknowledges his burial
and his resurrection and together they
tell the atoning work that Christ has
done for us now in Matthew 28 verses 18
through 20 Jesus said go therefore and
Make Disciples of all Nations
baptizing them in the name of the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit is that a
suggestion no this is Christ's Great
Commission to the church and what we
have to realize
baptism isn't going to save you but
baptism is the most crucial Act Your
First Act of obedience as a child of God
when you understand
what God is doing and you've given your
heart you should be baptized we looked
at Romans 6 3 through 6 that for
Annette's question that baptism is
signifying it's actually symbolic of
something God's doing in us when we are
born again and we're trusting in his
forgiveness that he's paid the penalty
and it it just symbolizes as we are
buried in this watery grave it
symbolizes that we're going to put the
past behind us God said forget the past
don't dwell on it see I'm doing a new
thing in you and suddenly it will spring
forward and then you come up out of the
water in newness of Life see baptism is
a public confession of Christ it is so
critical baptism is what joins us to the
body of Christ so now the thief on the
cross did he have time to be baptized no
it was he saved yes Jesus promised he
would be with him in Paradise by
immersion is that important if it
symbolizes a death in a burial and we
see in Matthew 3 16 Jesus went down in
the water and immediately came up out of
the water to go into the Wilderness and
be tempted we see in Acts 8 39 when
Philip baptized the eunuch we see that
there was this much water and it says
that he went down in the water her and
he came up out of the water I do believe
with all of my heart a child cannot
choose to be baptized it's an Act of
Faith I do believe with all of my heart
that what we should follow Christ's
example the word baptismal means to be
submerged what about sprinkling
the word baptismal fully means to be
submerged in water it is it's symbolic
that we're laying down that old life
we're identifying with Christ like a
marriage huh yeah your commitment
beautiful thank you all right
this is your question John this is uh
here it is what does one who this is a
quote one who takes up the plow and
looks back isn't fit for the kingdom
mean you know that's from Luke 9 62.
this is a form of viewer from New Jersey
okay New Jersey the tri-state area
yeah the tri-state area well thank you
for the question from the tri-state area
in New York City uh in New Jersey this
is in fact uh Dr Luke I believe
has a number of examples to draw from
one of the earliest ones we find in
scripture was the destruction of Sodom
and Gomorrah you know Dr Luke is the one
that records this short phrase remember
Lot's wife yes one of the shortest
passages in scripture remember Lot's
wife and the question is what happened
to Lot's wife well looking back is a
symbolic comparison to if the Lord is
calling you forward to safety and
destruction is behind you
remember Lot's wife what did she do
Genesis 19 verse 26. but his wife looked
behind him and she became a pillar of
salt Frozen between safety and
destruction she never went to complete
safety she'd never fully escaped
destruction she was Frozen in her
decision what was her last act she
looked back and that's a sad reality you
know if you're going to be the Bible
says a righteous man falls seven times
and a good friend of mine you know David
ashrik says you're going to fall fall in
the direction of the Kingdom oh yeah and
so but those who look back the Bible
made it very clear in Luke 9 verse 62
they are not fit for the kingdom why
because they're thinking about what's
behind them rather than what's in ahead
of them the example was given clearly
when the Lord again told the Israelites
when they were being pursued by the
Egyptians the Egyptians were not allowed
to catch up with them the Lord protected
them with a pill or a fire by night in
the cloud by day and he was always the
the wall between destruction and
protection and when they were frozen In
Their Fear Exodus 14 the Lord said to
Moses why do you cry to me tell the
children of Israel go forward and so we
find that anytime going forward is
recommended it's moving in the direction
of the Lord I press toward the mark
pressing toward the prize for the upward
call of God in Christ Jesus forgetting
those things was dropped behind me I
think of Philippians 3 verse 13 and 14
forgetting what's behind me pressing to
what's ahead of me and then you also
find going back as a symbol of apostasy
Falling Away John 6 66 from that time
many of us aside many of his disciples
went back and walked with him no more
now what happens Peter also Likens it to
apostasy but it's but it happened
according to the true proverb the dog
returned to his own vomit and a pig
having washed to her wallowing in the
mire second Peter chapter 2 verse 22
don't go back you're going back to the
worst things as well as you go going
back to destruction the recommendation
to the children of Israel and to you is
don't cry go forward amen there's a song
we used to listen to We Fall Down but we
get out that's right yeah when you fall
do not stay down that's right back up no
matter what you've done remember you can
get back up in Jesus he will lift you
and carry you all the way but you got to
trust him okay let's go all right here
we go this is your four minute question
James question yeah it's a short short
question but it's a four-minute answer
okay here we go must someone be a
Seventh-Day Adventist to serve God to go
to heaven this is a YouTube question
that is a big question and of course we
need to answer that with an emphatic no
you don't have to actually be of any
denomination in order to serve God and
to go to heaven you know there's going
to be a lot of people in heaven who
weren't connected with any kind of
denomination per se but we need to be
really cautious here as we're going to
see when we read these Bible verses the
first one I'd like to give you is in
Zechariah Chapter 13. you can read the
entire chapter it's all good but verse 6
talks about one who says unto him the
Lord what are these wounds in your hands
and he shall answer these with which I
was wounded in the house of my friends
there are going to be people in heaven
who are going to ask Jesus what happened
to him why does he have these wounds
because we're told Jesus is going to
Bear the wounds of the cross for all
eternity and he's going to explain to
them as he walks them by the River of
Life he's going to explain to him the
whole Plan of Salvation they didn't know
why not well because according to Romans
Chapter 2 there are going to be people
in heaven who didn't really know the law
or the truth or understand all the
things that the Jews understood or maybe
that we understood but they lived up to
their conscience they did what their
conscience told them was right to do
maybe they protected missionaries on
their Journeys and they they took care
care of poor people who were hungry they
did what their conscience told them and
their conscience became a law to them
let's read the verses Romans 2 verse 11
for there is no respect to persons with
God for as many as have sinned without
the law Shall Perish without the law and
as many as have sinned in the law shall
be judged by the law for not the hearers
of the law are just before God but the
doers of the law shall be justified for
when the Gentiles which have not the law
do by Nature the things contained in the
law these having not the law are a law
unto themselves which show the work of
the law written in their hearts their
conscience also bearing them witness and
their thoughts to Meanwhile excusing or
accusing or excusing one another in the
day when God shall judge the secrets of
men by Jesus Christ according to my
gospel now we know that there is no
salvation but in Jesus Christ but the
holy spirit is worthy and on the hearts
of every single person and revealing to
them whatever they can handle of the
Light of Christ the light of the
Everlasting gospel and if they will walk
in that light he shows them more and
more and more and there are going to be
people in heaven who walked in as much
light as as God was able to show them
and therefore they're going to be saved
because Jesus says I have other sheep
that are not of this fold that's John
chapter 10 and verse 16.
other sheep I have which are not of this
fold them also must I bring and there
shall be and they shall hear my voice
and there shall be one fold and one
Shepherd now we're transitioning into
what I believe is an important
factor in the end of time you see God
has a message he's going to take to all
the world Revelation 18 talks about
God's glory light in the whole earth and
he's going to call all of his people out
of Babylon that is out of confusion yeah
there's lots of different folds but
God's going to have one full in the end
of time and they're going to follow one
Shepherd in the end of time and this
Everlasting gospel is going to go to all
the world at the end of time and when
that happens people are going to become
enlightened with the gospel with the
truth of who Jesus is they're going to
accept him and they're going to become
part of the body of Christ now Shelley
mentioned earlier the importance of
being part of the body of Christ when
we're baptized we not only accept Jesus
but we can become part of the body of
Christ so I I want to emphasize this now
just to balance this out we don't have
to be part of the denomination to be
saved but if we have the light and the
truth of Church Fellowship of the body
of Christ we should walk in that light
and walk in that truth and become part
of the body of Christ so that we can
edify one another and build one another
up and be directed by Christ who is the
head of that spiritual body you can read
about that in First Corinthians chapter
12. and then in Acts chapter 2 verse 47
won't close with this verse the early
church was filled with the Holy Spirit
they're preaching the Gospel of Jesus
Christ they were praising God they were
having favor with all the people and the
Lord added to the church daily such as
should be saved so may God add you to
his church in these last days amen and
we know in Acts 17 30 at times of
ignorance God winked at so now he
commands everyone to repent amen amen so
Heaven's going to be a beautiful place
many people from throughout time will be
there and it's going to be exciting
meeting all these people that are part
of the family of God thank you all right
Shelley
here we go
can you explain can you please help me
to understand what spiritual pride is
this is from Marie and Papua New Guinea
oh Marie what a wonderful question I'm
sorry I only have three minutes to
answer it
spiritual Pride yes
um it sounds like an oxymoron if you
were to add Christian in front of it it
is an oxymoron it's it would be uh it's
not compatible but what happens we know
Satan had spiritual Pride right he
exalted himself when someone boasts
or feel Superior to
or exalts themself or their
self-righteousness that spiritual Pride
you know God's plan of salvation by
grace through faith is very humbling God
expects us to depend totally upon him
and we don't take any credit for what
he's done
when a
a person
is say a pastor
who has all of the talents and the
possessions that God has given and he
gets up and gives a great message and
you go say oh oh that's that was such a
wonderful message if he gets a little
puffed up about it guess what you just
made him have spiritual pride and that
we none of us can take
any credit for the gifts that God has
given us or as he has developed them now
yes we're to cooperate but no teacher of
the word even has a reason for boasting
in First Corinthians 4 7 Paul says
who makes you differ from another and
what do you have that you did not
receive now if you did not receive it
why do you boast as if you had not
received it boasting of any sort that's
deceitful it leads us to feeling
Superior we've got to remember God is
The Giver of every good and perfect gift
real quickly I've got to read this first
Chronicles 29 11-12 this is David
praying and he says yours O Lord is the
greatness the power and the glory the
Victory and the Majesty for all that is
in heaven and earth is yours yours is
the kingdom oh Lord you are exalted as
head over all both riches and honor come
from you and you Reign Over All We can't
even feel prideful about the wealth that
we have attained in your hand is power
and might in your hand it is to make
great and to to give strength to all but
get this verse 14.
we can't even be proud about our ability
to give or how much we give David says
who am I and who are my people that we
should be able to offer so willingly is
this for all things come from you and of
your own we have given you God provides
everything there's no room for Spiritual
Pride amen wow well said and you know
all of you on 3abn you've seen all over
the world and people will come and say
oh we just love your sermons we always
give it back to the Lord amen always
give it back to the Lord we say praise
the Lord if he could use me what we
always say honey I'm just just the
lampshade Jesus is the light he's the
light
if you've just tuned in and you have
Bible questions you can text us at
618-228-3975 or you can email us if you
prefer at bibleqa at 3abn.tv
okay let's go to the next question honey
here's this is your question
please help me understand First Timothy
4 3-5 but how do we explain these verses
of scripture
that you such plain language as to
suggest we can eat anything as long as
it is Sanctified by the word through
prayer what do these verses really mean
this is from Brian in Spokane thank you
Brian for that question now there's a
lot to unpack on these verses that's why
I didn't take a lot of time to add a
whole lot more verses because this verse
is a mouthful to be very candid about it
so I'll just go ahead and read as we
lead as we lean into it first Timothy
chapter four beginning with the verse
one you know somebody wants his context
text without context is pretext let's
understand what Paul is telling Timothy
he is saying now the spirit expressly
says that in the latter times some will
depart from the faith that is the
purpose of and he's going to say this is
how you can identify those that are
departing from the faith that is what
he's identifying so he's saying this is
a list of things they will do kind of
like a Daniel 9 all the things that the
Lord is going to accomplish or hopes to
accomplish among Israel in a similar way
it says they're going to start by giving
heed to deceiving spirits and doctrines
of demons that's the first thing the
other one they're going to be speaking
lies in hypocrisy by denying the truth
the third one their conscience will be
seared with a hot iron meaning they know
all they are no longer receptive to the
voice and the workings of the Holy
Spirit the other one they forbid to
marry
and they forbid meat that are Sanctified
by the word of God in prayer and that's
the key because since we focused more on
the Meat part in the eating part we'll
spend a little time on the prior things
what this seems to suggest as you put
this in the context if you put the whole
picture together somebody might say well
as we get closer to the end does it
become permissible now to eat things in
the latter times that's not what Paul is
saying that's not what he's telling
Timothy he is saying if you're going to
eat anything make sure it is Sanctified
by the word of God first of all what
does that mean Sanctified meaning God's
word sets things aside and when you
follow scriptures you find that
throughout the Bible from Genesis all
the way through in the specifics the
things we can and cannot eat God
specified that through the Jewish Nation
intending to tell the world as you find
Acts chapter 13 verse 42-44 says God
intended them to be a light to the
Gentiles to the rest of the world so the
Lord outlined and clearly how he wanted
our bodies to be treated and the key
issue is does God's word sanctify what
we eat what does it mean set it aside
and is it holy for food consumption
that's the key to it the other thing is
if it is
then the word of God says pray over it
and thank the Lord for it now one of the
things that happened in the days of Paul
were there were some Jews that were
taking things to the market that had
already been sacrificed and it was a
concern so he says is it Sanctified by
God's word yes
so then don't ask whether or not it's it
was used for sacrifices that was not
necessarily the context for this
particular scripture but here's the key
in summary if God's word sanctifies it
and sets it aside for food consumption
all you got to do is pray and thank the
Lord for it
all right thank you for that
good answer okay
James Rafferty here's your question
is Proverbs 1 verse 20 to 32 talking
about God or Solomon it seems not to be
God's character to Vin to be Vindicated
vindictive or mean-spirited this is
Trina from Mariposa California that's a
great question Trina and I agree with
you it doesn't line up with God's
character to be mean-spirited or of
indicative but there are principles of
God's character that are just and holy
and righteous Proverbs Chapter 1 is
indeed God speaking and he is speaking
to Solomon and speaking to us through
Solomon verses 20-32 and the controversy
really is over the character of God
because God is both merciful and he is
just and righteous and holy and his
character has been at the center of this
great controversy so sometimes when we
read these Bible verses we think oh that
can't be God and that's because perhaps
we've been given the wrong picture of
what God is really like for example God
is sometimes pictured as being just so
just on the one hand that he can't be
merciful or so merciful on the other
hand that he can't be a God of Justice
Calvary kind of settles all of that
because when you look at Calvary you see
God being just and God be merciful at
the same time you see Justice and mercy
being reconciled on Calvary Jesus died
in that or manifestation of God's mercy
toward us Jesus died in an actor of
manifestation of God's justice towards
sin and so we see this reconciliation
taking place on Calvary and again when
you look at the Bible you recognize that
the revelation of God's character is
this balance of justice and mercy for
example the Ten Commandments in
commandment number two
verse 5 of Exodus 20. it says Thou shalt
not bow down thyself to them nor serve
them for the for I am the Lord thy God
am a jealous God visiting the iniquity
of the fathers upon the children under
the third and fourth generation of them
that hate me so God is actually keeping
record of and visiting iniquity upon
people but then he goes on to say and
showing Mercy unto thousands of them
that love me and keep my commandments so
there you have this Justice and this
Mercy in the character of God God is
helping us to understand the balance or
the tension between the justice and the
mercy of his character in a sense you
could say the emphasis in the Old
Testament is God's justice and the
emphasis in the New Testament it's God's
mercy and both together bring us a full
picture of who God really is
thank you for that great answer okay
Shelly this is your four minute question
okay okay here we go is it wrong to
teach the things God has revealed to us
concerning the Prophecies of the last
days the Commandments and the Sabbath I
was told if I was not considered a
teacher then God would hold me
accountable I take the text in Ezekiel
33 very seriously and I believe as a
faithful follower of Christ I am bound
to share the warnings of the signs of
God's soon return Rebecca from Oregon
Rebecca I believe that's the loving
thing to do and let's look at scripture
first of all Ezekiel 33 in context it is
speaking of the Prophet that god holds
accountable if they if God gives them a
warning to tell the people to repent and
the prophet doesn't then God says hey if
you don't give the trumpet a certain
sound their blood's on your hands so
um does that apply to us let me just set
that aside for now here's the main thing
Matthew 28 18-20 is the Great Commission
when Jesus said that he is telling us to
go and Make Disciples of all Nations
teaching them everything
that he wants us to obey he's actually
speaking to all of us we all have that
call to fulfill the Great Commission
Ephesians chapter 4 verses 11 through 16
talks about the apostles the prophets
the pastors the evangelists the teachers
what is their job they are to equip the
Saints for the work of ministry and he
goes on in just a couple more verses
saying speak the truth in love so that
we can all grow up so I think the loving
thing to do if I saw someone heading
toward a cliff or a washed out bridge if
I didn't warn them that wouldn't be love
Revelation 14 6. here's what I want to
say to you Rebecca
Revelation 14 6 we see through 12 The
Three Angels messages
and you know what if we only give the
warnings of the Three Angels messages
nobody's going to listen the Three
Angels message starts off it says I saw
another Angel flying in the midst of
Heaven having the Everlasting gospel to
preach to everyone every tongue and
tribe in people so what we have to do
speaking the truth and love before you
can warn somebody I mean if you tell me
don't take the mark of the beast and I
don't know what what the Everlasting
gospel is that Jesus died for me it's
meaningless so we need to learn to share
Jesus first then share the warnings
Revelation 12 17 says the dragon was
enraged with the woman he went to make
war with the rest of our Offspring for
those who keep the Commandments of God
and have the testimony of Jesus Christ
the testimony of Jesus Christ we're to
be out testifying about how our God came
to Earth became a man died for us became
our substitute to let people know how
much he loves them we know the testimony
of Jesus Christ is the spirit of
Prophecy it starts in Genesis and goes
all the way to the end of a revelation
and you know Paul says how can people
hear if we don't go somebody we don't
send somebody to them Romans 10 15. he
says how beautiful are the feet of those
who preach the gospel of peace do I
believe that you don't have the right to
share the prophecies or the Commandments
or the warnings absolutely not I think
it is your duty as a Christian just be
sure that you're speaking the truth in
love that you're sharing the testimony
of who Jesus is before you give those
warnings amen man well said and Jesus as
we know John 10 10 and Thief come steal
kill and destroyed but God has come that
we may have life and have it more
abundantly and these truths the truth
don't have us well how do we always say
that yeah we don't have the truth the
truth that's what you always say yeah we
don't have the true truth happens wow
well what we're going to do is take a
short break but when we come back we're
going to get some closing thoughts from
the panel so we'll be right back
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3abian Bible q a for answers from
God's word
I hope you were blessed I sure was and I
always learn a lot when I listened to
the panel from these wonderful answers
for Bible q a does anyone have any
closing thoughts yeah I have a thought
I'd like to share with that last
question because it was a difficult
question and that was about the
character of God is he vindictive Etc
and sometimes it's our perspective you
know when I think about Christ hanging
on the cross and crying out my God my
God why hast Thou forsaken me that seems
a little vindictive that seems a little
mean-spirited why would God forsake his
son right at the very time when Jesus
needed him the most but when you look
into the heart of God and when you look
into the what was really happening there
God was actually right there at the
throne he I mean at the cross he was
veiled in darkness but Jesus of course
couldn't feel his presence and sometimes
you know we've it's our feelings that
disconnect us from God or make us
misunderstand what God is really like
we've got to go to the word of God and
the word of God is very clear that God
so loved the world that he gave his only
begotten son God loves us and he does
everything he can to redeem us I love
the story of Nebuchadnezzar when he was
you know made crazy for seven years and
you know you think oh that's vindictive
that's mean spirited why did God do that
make him like an animal you know eating
grass like and but when he comes out of
it when Nebuchadnezzar comes out of it
he's like God it's so good yes he knows
how to Humble the proud and he just he
knows what he's doing I'm just going to
trust him and sometimes we need to go
just to the word of God and trust God
and not allow our feelings in the way we
might think about him in a negative way
to overpower the revelation of his
father amen amen Shelly you have any
closing thoughts just a quick one on the
clean and unclean when I was studying in
Genesis recently when God set aside
clean animals and unclean clean means
they're acceptable to God unclean means
they're not acceptable clean means they
are Sanctified so what is Sanctified by
the word of God from First Timothy we
have to make sure that we're following
God's counsel thank you I'll try it and
the other thing is God created All
Creatures so you might ask yourself why
would he create something that's clean
and unclean for what clean for
consumption unclean consumption God
built into creation his own sanitation
department that's why the world's so
beautiful the forest the Wilderness the
ocean so trust God's word and you'll
always be guided in the right direction
thank you so much all three of you you
did a wonderful job and thank you the
Lord used you all in a beautiful way
thank you until next time you have a
blessed day and read the word of God for
nourishment God bless you
thank you
[Music]